as we always say on any given day half
the country is angry at us I don't
believe it's half the country I think
it's a third
yeah but every fan of the view is
cheering today it's a lot because Whoopi
Goldberg Joy Behar Sonny hasten Sarah
Gaines along with newbies Alyssa Farah
Griffin and Ana Navarro are back for the
talk shows 26th season it is such an
honor and just privilege to be here I'm
so excited chatting with ET on the set
the ladies explain how they plan to
leave their hot topics at the table I
vent if I didn't vent I'd never survived
here in any kind of a job but no this
group is very cohesive I think you know
I have no idea I just leave I go home
and go home to my life and I take care
of my cat and do all the stuff I'm
supposed to do there are times actually
over the years where you do take it
personally and that's almost more your
job to work on than theirs because there
have been times where with help from my
husband my therapist I even my producer
I'll have to step back and say okay
let's talk about that why are you
feeling so you know hit by this and it
usually is your own stuff it's your own
baggage it's your own Journey it was
never about anyone else Alyssa Fair
Griffin who recently filled the
conservative seat on the panel tells E.T
cooler heads usually Prevail you
sometimes can watch the segments where
the hottest ones that we have and then
as the camera starts to pull away to go
to commercial we're chatting about our
dog so we're talking about like what
your plans were over the weekend so
there's a level of friendship and
respect there that I think goes a long
way I was just saying to Alyssa you know
it's not what you say on this show it's
how you say it and so she's a
conservative she and I disagree
politically I know so what good we're
happy to have somebody like that just
don't make it personal and don't be an
attack dog and then I'll try not to be
and that's how we do it we try to keep
as much energy going as we can with the
things we talk about and try to see as
many sides as we can so it can get
tiring sometimes and it's also there's
an understanding that the show is better
when there is some disagreement so like
disagree don't have to be disagreeable
and like I go in thinking I just want to
show the other side's perspective I'm
not looking to change everyone's mind if
that makes sense to sit at this table to
have a you know the institution the
brand itself is so iconic and I've been
a fan since the beginning then you add
the faces and you allow that awe to be
your guidance which means you got to be
strong you got to speak up
but you're so honored to be there that
it's it's
um
it's kind of easy it comes natural to
respect and walk away and be okay with
that I was just telling somebody else to
me longevity is the main thing in this
business because you can have a job in a
movie and then nobody sees you again but
this longevity is key
[Music]